economía en france 24 con louis semen de
su leche y volvemos para hacer un repaso
louis de la agenda del día la
organización internacional del trabajo
reveló el impacto de la pandemia en el
empleo cuéntenos sobre ello se debe
decir que este impacto ha superado las
previsiones que el propio organismo
había planteado meses atrás y
responsabiliza de la situación un
estancamiento dentro de la recuperación
mundial de acuerdo con el informe las
horas trabajadas en comparación con el
cuarto trimestre del año 2019
disminuyeron en 4 3% o el equivalente a
125 millones de empleo a tiempo completo
la cifra supera la estimación de 100
millones de empleos que estaba prevista
en su último informe presentado en junio
pero escuchemos que otras cosas dijeron
dentro de la organización world wildlife
found precaver y esto en tránsito en
chihuaha la recuperación del mercado
global se ha estancado en 2021 el
principio de este año como mostró
nuestro informe anterior anticipábamos
que iba a ser una frágil pero estable
recuperación tras el impacto del colín
pero ese optimismo de aquel momento se
ha borrado
y por otro lado en cuanto a la
productividad o la relación entre el
producto interno bruto y las horas
trabajadas américa latina se situó por
debajo de la media global que estuvo por
el orden de los 18,9 totales
y continuamos en colombia el banco
mundial le dio a conocer que la pandemia
amplió las desigualdades en el país se
desprende de un informe presentado por
el organismo este miércoles y alerta que
la situación podría tener un impacto un
efecto prolongado de acuerdo con el
documento la desigualdad en colombia
según el banco mundial y medida en
cuanto a la distribución de ingresos es
la más alta entre los países miembros de
la organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico por otro lado el
documento señala que los ingresos del
10% de la población con mayores recursos
son 11 veces mayores que el 10 por
ciento de los ciudadanos más pobres
asimismo el informe señala que tras la
pandemia al menos 36 millones de
personas fueron arrastradas a la pobreza
al tiempo que si tomamos la pobreza
extrema ésta se incrementó en un 55 por
ciento o el equivalente a 2,8 millones
de personas escuchemos que dijeron
durante la presentación del informe
las desigualdades están ligadas a donde
vive la persona en gran medida de hecho
las desigualdades en colombia son dos
veces más altas que en otros países de
la oecd
a la izquierda en este mapa vemos que
las desigualdades regionales son amplias
en colombia'
la región más vulnerable en términos de
condiciones socioeconómicas es la
amazonía que es casi dos veces más
vulnerable que la región central y ni
siquiera empecemos a hablar de
informalidad vamos a pasar ahora a
brasil porque el gobierno afina sus
estrategias para frenar la inflación y
por ello el día de hoy se conoció que la
comisión de política monetaria elevó en
150 puntos base de la tasa de referencia
su más alto ajuste en casi dos décadas
este ha sido el mayor incremento desde
diciembre del año 2002 y ubicó la tasa
de referencia en 7 75 por ciento el
mayor nivel en los últimos cuatro años
el dato superó las expectativas de los
analistas y ha provocado reacciones en
el sector de la industria que calificó
el incremento como excesivo este aumento
busca disminuir un poco la cantidad de
dinero circulante y obligará al ahorro
además de disminuir o disminuir los
gastos en la población y vamos a seguir
hablando de los informes trimestrales
como hicimos ayer porque la empresa
boeing le dio a conocer sus resultados
esto fueron un poco mejor que los dado a
conocer en el mismo período del año
pasado pero no se alejan de las pérdidas
productos los problemas que ha tenido la
empresa con él los equipos de acuerdo
con la compañía los ingresos
trimestrales se ubicaron por el orden de
los 15 mil 280 millones de dólares la
cifra revela un aumento de 8% respecto
al mismo período del año pasado pero que
estuvo por debajo de las previsiones de
los analistas- la pérdida informada por
la compañía se ubicó en 132 millones de
dólares en este periodo y en europa pero
no la unión europea reino unido se
muestra en buena actitud de con buenas
previsiones sobre su economía así lo voy
a conocer el canciller de hacienda
crisis sunat durante su discurso sobre
el presupuesto presentado en el
parlamento y en el que proyecta un
crecimiento económico de 65 % es decir
2,5 puntos porcentuales por encima de
los 4 proyectados anteriormente y ahora
si los indicadores de las jornadas hay
que señalar que en estados unidos
cerraron con números mixtos durante de
la jornada por otro lado en europa hubo
cierres negativos a lo largo del día ya
comenzó las operaciones en el mercado
japonés con números negativos américa
latina también tuvo cierres negativos a
lo largo
nos vemos mañana luis y seguimos en
france 24
[Música]
i